Hey, you big, dumb idiots!
We got the grand prize,
the Predator statue.
Come collect it.
Show me.
Where is it?
Are you blind?
It's right there.
(low voice)
♪ Baby ♪
It's real.
It's legit.
Great, come on out,
individually.
(Adam)
[grunts] Stop!
How stupid
do you think we are?
- Get--
- We can see
it's your dumbass friend
dressed up.
[bleep].
Is that a Falkor car?
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah, it is.
- We made it ourselves.
- We did.
We're thinking of taking photos
and putting it on Pinterest.
It's, like, do-it-yourself.
It's like, you can also do this
if you have the time
and the willpower.
What's the deal?
You a big Neverending Story fan?
It's a good movie.
What? Oh.
Does a rockbiter
bite rocks?
That's a cool tattoo.
It looks like, uh...
Like a gigantic
gaping butthole.
Unique.
You're a unique person.
You guys like drag racing,
right?
We've been known to drift.
How 'bout we race
for pink slips?
You win,
you get the Fal-car.
We win, you guys just
bounce on out of here,
and then sort of admit
that I'm
the most Atreyu-looking dude
you've ever met.
Great, deal.
Let's do it.
Okay.
[car alarm chirp]
[engine revving]
(low voice)
♪ Baby ♪
Rude!
You'd have my job?
That's right, and it would
only take me five years
to take it.
Impressed?
Why would I hire someone
who wants to take my job away?
I'm smarter than I look,
and I know that I look
pretty smart.
I'm not sure
I get that exactly.
Hey, guys.
Still in the middle of this.
No, I get that,
I totally do,
but we got to race
these movie buffs
or they're gonna knock
out our teeth out.
I think I'll be leaving now.
- Hey!
- Ahh!
Don't make me
kick your asses.
Let's go!
I think I'll be
staying now.
(Adam)
What if I gave you
a Westley mask?
Help us, Dersy.
As you wish.
[engines revving]
First one past the fence,
bro.
That's right.
Luckdragon's about to be
mine, baby.
All right.
Wait, what's he
talking about?
Oh.
Okay, on Jenny's go.
Okay, Jenny!
[engines revving]
['80s action movie music]
[tires screeching]
- Wait, wait, wait! Oh, no!
- Stop!
(Anders)
Wait, what?
Speed bumps, they're not
just for hockey anymore.
[mellow hip-hop music]
♪ ♪
You lose.
Ah.
[pounding on roof.
(both)
Whoo!
Yeah!
That was cool, right?
- That worked.
(Adam) Oh, yeah.
That was the most interesting
interview
I have ever been
a part of.